okay das ist das schwierigste Meile
video ever es ist halt auch kein
typisches smile-app-video
wäre es ein typisches Meile wie du dann
wäre es einfach dann würde es so
anfangen meine euer
lieblingswissenschaftskanal der immer
für euch da ist bei dem ihr euch darauf
verlassen könnt dass alles stimmt außer
die Behauptung dass jeden zweiten
Donnerstag um 6:30 Uhr ein neues Video
kommt ein Kanal dem trotz humorvoller
Aufarbeitung Seriosität immer wichtig
ist auch wenn vor clickbait nicht
zurückgeschreckt wird das Ende von
schönen schlau war letztendlich nur eine
Umbenennung in mylap in Burnout hat sich
mal in einen Pause unbekannter Länge
verabschiedet mit dem Versprechen
zurückzukommen und das tat sie auch und
in das war's verabschiedete sie sich
wieder dieses Mal in Babypause doch auch
hier kam meine zurück sogar mit einem
vergrößerten Team aber jetzt hat meine
ein neues Video hochgeladen mit dem
Titel das Ende von Meile ist es wieder
clickbait oder steck dieses Mal mehr
dahinter das klären wir hier einfach mal
holt euch ein Thema macht es euch
gemütlich wir steigen durch
ach Leute in einem Punkt ist es wirklich
ein typisches mylab-video und zwar muss
ich jetzt am Anfang erstmal ein bisschen
weiter ausholen um das Ganze überhaupt
erstverständlich zu machen also fangen
wir ganz vorne an im April 2016 bekam
ich eine Nachricht von einer Melanie
gart die mir erzählte sie arbeitet beim
spbr und möchte einen wissenskanal
aufbauen für das junge Angebot von ARD
und ZDF das war der Arbeitstitel damals
von Funk melanie hatte mich über meinen
damaligen hobby-kanal the secret life of
scientist gefunden was ziemlich crazy
ist weil ich habe gerade noch mal
nachgeschaut ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt
weniger als 2000 Abonnenten hatte im
September 2016 fing ich mit Melanie
zusammen den Funkkanal schön schlauer an
das passe ganz gut denn im Sommer 2016
hatte ich meine Doktorarbeit abgegeben
und ich dachte noch ja ich mache jetzt
mal so Sabbatjahr ich mache ein Jahr
Funk das wird bestimmt ganz witzig und
danach gehe ich in die Forschung zurück
dass ich da nie wieder hin
zurückgegangen bin ist zu einem
wesentlichen Teil Melanie zu verdanken
ihr kennt Melanie als unsere Grafikerin
wir haben auch immer gemeinsam die
Themen ausgewählt und alles skriptet
beschlossen ich habe mich um die
wissenschaftliche Recherche gekrümmert
und umschreiben und natürlich um die
Produktion also am Anfang sehr low
budget deswegen alles an mit einer
weißen Wand einem Stativ und einer
Webcam aber melanie hatte noch eine ganz
essentielle Rolle und zwar war sie die
sogenannte abnehmende Redakteurin das
ist erstmal offiziell ein wichtiger
Posten jeder Beitrag muss abgenommen
also freigegeben werden das war also
Melanies Verantwortung auf Seiten des
SWR aber nicht nur das sie hat mir
metaphorisch gesprochen ein Haus gebaut
in dem ich perfekt arbeiten konnte sie
hat mir bei den Rücken frei gehalten und
meine Freiheit als creatorin und als
nötige Wissenschaftlerin sichergestellt
das war am Anfang vielleicht auch etwas
einfacher als wir noch ein kleiner Kanal
waren und so ein bisschen under the
Raider bin schlau hatte jetzt 10.000
Abonnenten was sagen sie dazu
was ist schön schlau aber wir wurden ja
dann mit viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit und
Reichweite belohnt und um diese
Aufmerksamkeit gerecht zu werden stecken
wir immer mehr Arbeit in die Videos so
dass wir bald Verstärkung brauchen Lars
wurde Teil des Teams dr Lars Dietrich
Biologe und schlagforscher eigentlich
waren wir nur in Kontakt weil er als
Experte in diesem Video über
schlafenmangel auftrat doch dann wurde
Lars mein erster Mitarbeiter und Lars
war für mich ein Wendepunkt oder ein
Knackpunkt weil vor Lars vieles mir sehr
schwer Menschen zu vertrauen wenn es um
wissenschaftliche Inhalte ging also
meine größte Angst ist immer irgendwas
Falsches zu erzählen ich habe den ersten
ein sehr ausgeprägtes
Verantwortungsbewusstsein
und es wäre mir natürlich super peinlich
und eine
Verletzung meiner chemischen Ehre
deshalb sehe ich mich übrigens auch
nicht als Moderatorin das ist zwar Teil
meines Jobs aber ich muss halt immer
genau wissen was ich davon mir gebe und
weil in der Medienbranche natürlich
nicht so viele Menschen mit
wissenschaftlichem Background Arbeiten
vieles mir immer sehr schwer da
Kontrolle abzugeben und es ist
sicherlich auch gut Kontrolle zu haben
aber wenn man halt nie was delegiert
also nie auch mal Aufgaben abgibt dann
ist man natürlich beschränkt in dem was
man schaffen kann oder läuft hat in
Burnout lars hat mich da echt gerettet
denn ähm nicht nur vertraue ich las zu
100 %. ich möchte inzwischen sogar gar
nichts mehr machen und das ist Lars dich
zumindest einmal kritisch beugt hat also
er ist nicht nur super intelligent und
kompetent sondern auch der kritischste
und sorgfältigste Mensch den ich kenne
und so konnte ich so ein shift machen
von ich muss alles selbst kontrollieren
und selbst machen hinzu
auch ich hätte gerne noch so ein Lars
und der kam dann auch und heißt sogar
fast so Jens mein zweiter Mitarbeiter
und viertes Mal Mitglied dr Jens Fell
Neuropsychologe und Schmerzforscher fast
wäre er Professor geworden davon konnten
wir ihn zum Glück noch abhalten jens hat
2020 bei mir angefangen also wo wir mit
unserem ganzen Corona Content auf jeden
Fall Nerd Verstärkung gebraucht hatten
aber inzwischen ist Jens auch überhaupt
nicht mehr wegzudenken und der Kanal
wurde ja auch irgendwann richtig groß
hat die eine Million Abonnenten geknackt
und with great abozahl com Scrat
responsibility so haben wir das
zumindest immer verspürt also wir haben
auch immer seltener Videos hochgeladen
von ein Video pro Woche zu ein Video
alle zwei Wochen und dann irgendwann ein
Video alle paar Wochen bis Monate
ein Grund für die abnehmende Frequenz
ist definitiv dass wir halt super viel
Respekt vor diese Reichweite haben wir
wollen hier nicht irgendwas hochladen
sondern nur Premium stuff wir stecken
natürlich immer mehr Arbeit in diese
Videos mit Erwachsenen Reichweite wuchs
auch unser Ehrgeiz ich glaube viele
Youtuber kennen das Gefühl weswegen sie
auch neben ihren Hauptkanälen dann
zweitkanäle aufmachen mit weniger Druck
und mit ihren Hauptkanälen halt nicht so
inflationär umzugehen also für uns war
meine auf jeden Fall irgendwann so eine
heilige Kuh hier kann man halt nicht
irgendwas hochladen und 2020 ist ja noch
was anderes großes passiert bei mir
privat nehme ich der Inhalt dieser Kugel
kam zur Welt und das hat bei mir
tatsächlich alles verändert also alle
meine Prioritäten haben sich verschoben
ihr kennt das ja vielleicht aus
Erfahrungsberichten anderer Youtuber
also wenn man nur youTube macht ist das
so ein
überfallzeit Job also was heißt Youtube
ich glaube man muss unterscheiden
zwischen YouTube als Plattform oder
ausspielen weg und Youtuber sein Creator
sein es gibt ja auch viele Kanäle bei
denen die Arbeit Prozesse so
funktionieren wie in einer
Fernsehproduktion nur dass das
Endprodukt am Ende halt nicht im
Fernsehen sondern online ausgestrahlt
wird und es gibt das oldschool Youtuber
sein wo man alles selbst in der Hand hat
und bei Meile bin ich da ein ganz
klassischer Youtuberin was übrigens
absolut Special ist ne für ein Funkkanal
dass ich meine in der Praxis so operiere
als sei es mein privater Kanal denn in
dem öffentlich-rechtlichen System gibt
es eigentlich sehr viel Bürokratie und
Abnahme Schleifen das ist doch alles gut
und richtig weil man ja mit dem
Rundfunkbeitrag verantwortungsvoll
umgehen muss und eine Qualitätskontrolle
sicherstellen muss das kann aber
gleichzeitig auch sehr bremsen und
unflexibel machen und es ist wie gesagt
Melanie zu verdanken dass wir uns da
gegenüber Funk und um SWR das Vertrauen
erarbeiten konnten und dann bei Meile
diese Freiheit Flexibilität und Autarkie
also völlige Selbstständigkeit hatten
für mich waren Fernsehen und Youtube da
immer eine super Ergänzung also im
Fernsehen wirklich tolle Dinge erleben
in Höhlen absteigen Experimente machen
Youtube saß ich dann halt allein im
Zimmer im Fernsehen konnte ich mit
großen kompetenten Teams
zusammenarbeiten war dafür halt
eingeschränkter in der Freiheit und
Umsetzung meiner eigenen Ideen bei
Youtube hatte ich viel mehr
Verantwortung und natürlich auch viel
mehr Arbeit aber die Verantwortung fand
ich immer sehr belohnend also ich habe
gerne Verantwortung und hatte natürlich
volle Kontrolle und Freiheit bei der
Umsetzung und genau deswegen habe ich
die extra Arbeit bei Youtube immer super
gerne in Kauf genommen bzw das hat sich
sogar nie so richtig wie Arbeit
angefühlt
ist ich Mutter wurde jetzt weiß ich es
viel mehr zu schätzen dass es im
Fernsehen Staffeln und staffelpausen
gibt oder sich mal eine größere
terrax-doku drehe dann aber auch eine
längere kamerapause habe bis zur
nächsten dass ich immer mein ganzes Jahr
im Voraus planen kann so dass ich genau
weiß wann habe ich drei Tage wann kann
ich mich auf das redaktionelle
konzentrieren wann kann ich Urlaub
machen in meiner Arbeit Prioritätenliste
ist seitdem Mutter sein Kontrolle haben
weiter nach unten gerutscht und dafür
Dinge wie Planbarkeit oder keine
Überstunden machen nach oben ich werde
sicher immer viel arbeiten und zwar sehr
gerne denn ich liebe meinen Job und
empfinde ihn als großes Privileg und
dass ich nicht einfach was moderieren
will sondern in erster Linie innerlich
arbeiten will das hat sich nicht
geändert das wird sich auch nicht ändern
das heißt immer wenn ich keine Drehtage
habe aber ich redaktionell aber ich muss
mir dafür halt irgendwie nachhaltige
Strukturen schaffen die mir innerlich
alle Freiheit geben aber
traditionell nicht zu 100% auf mir
aufgebaut sind und nachdem ich jetzt
lange Fernsehen und Youtube parallel
gemacht habe also im Fernsehen bin ich
ja zwischen beim ZDF ich mache da zum
Beispiel regelmäßig mehrteilige Terre
xdokus hat eine Sache mein Arbeitsalltag
am meisten verändert nämlich my
thinkings wo ich natürlich moderiere
aber wo ich auch die wissenschaftliche
Leitung habe und überhaupt das ist halt
meine Sendung in der ich alles bestimmen
kann aber nicht muss dank eines großen
Teams und ja so viele Menschen braucht
man um so eine Sendung auf die Bühne zu
bringen und ohne daily basis vor allem
dann diesen Menschen hier es war
natürlich am Anfang eine Herausforderung
ich muss doch erstmal selbst rausfinden
wo ich mit dieser Sendung hin will aber
inzwischen sind wir da wirklich
angekommen also ich bin zumindest super
happy und stolz über die Entwicklung die
die Sendung gemacht hat und
interessanterweise ist der
psychologische Druck im Fernsehen nicht
so groß wie bei Youtube finde ich also
wir erreichen bei Mike x
zusammengenommen ähnlich viele Menschen
wie bei Terra x noch deutlich mehr und
ich kann mich über diese Reichweite viel
freier freuen mit weniger Druck weil
nicht alles auf meinen Schultern lastet
und ich muss sagen es geht mir echt viel
Energie Publikum zu haben ich bin ein
bühnenkind ich habe ja
Wissenschaftskommunikation auch auf der
Bühne angefangen ich habe vorher sehr
lange getanzt auf Bühnen ich finde das
macht am meisten Spaß also diese Live
Energie direkt zurück zu bekommen
gleichzeitig fing es so 2021 an
dass ich mich manchmal dabei ertappte
wie mich malep stresste zum Beispiel
gerade meist in X Staffel abgedreht und
eigentlich müsste ein bisschen
durchschnaufen und eine Auszeit oder
family time nehmen und obwohl mein
Management da sehr gut auf mich aufpasst
und mir dann Urlaub blockiert den ich
sonst von alleine nicht genommen hätte
habe ich halt immer diese Stimme im Kopf
so du musst machen jetzt muss aber
wirklich meine machen nur vernachlässigt
diesen Kanal und jetzt sowas wie Inhalte
zu machen die weniger Arbeit sind
einfach nur um diesen Kanal zu bespielen
das kam für mich halt auch nicht in
Frage so
und jetzt sind zwei major Dinge passiert
erstens
und zweitens Melanie
wenn ihr vorhin aufmerksam zugehört habt
melanie hatte Rasi das war also Melanies
Verantwortung über den Rücken frei
gehalten ja Vergangenheitsform melanie
hat vor kurzem den SWR verlassen aus
privaten Gründen sie ist in die Schweiz
gezogen und musste damit auch schweren
Herzens der Smiley im Team verlassen
damit habe ich jetzt eine Freundin die
ich in der Schweiz besuchen kann
aber natürlich eine sehr wichtige
Partnerin verloren ich habe lange
überlegt wie ich in Zukunft an meine
festhalten kann mit zwei Kindern und
ohne Melanie
zum Beispiel indem man die Frequenz noch
weiter senkt was aber natürlich den
Druck dafür dann umso geileren Content
zu machen nicht gerade kleiner sondern
noch größer macht und auch wenn Funk
oder der SWR mich nie also wirklich zu
keinem Zeitpunkt unter Druck gesetzt
haben Content zu machen also wir waren
eher immer besorgt um meine live-balance
nee ich halt so und Jens und Lars auch
und das ist vielleicht auch gut so dass
wir uns diesen Druck machen oder diesen
Ehrgeiz haben denn nur so macht man ja
gute Arbeit monatelang habe ich mit mir
gerungen und kam am Ende zu dem Schluss
dass jetzt ein guter also guter
Zeitpunkt ist um
mit meinem aufzuhören um einen Kapitel
abzuschließen werde ich nie wieder
Youtube machen
naja also wahrscheinlich werde ich immer
irgendwie Videos machen also Videos
selbst machen macht ja auch sehr viel
Spaß und ich habe ja auch alles hier
also hier das Ringlicht ist mein
Schreibtisch Licht natürlich wird auch
dieser Kanal nicht gelöscht oder so ne
also falls ihr mal noch mal nachschauen
wollt ob ein bisschen Alkohol gesund ist
nein ist es nicht Videos machen wird
wahrscheinlich immer mindestens mal ein
Hobby bleiben aber beruflich zusammen
mit Funk schließt sich hier für mich
erstmal ein Kapitel das geht mir
natürlich auch die Zeit und die Luft für
neue Kapitel also ich mache jetzt
natürlich erstmal Babypause und danach
kommen so ein paar neue Projekte ich
kann da jetzt noch nicht so viel zu
verraten ich habe mir jedenfalls in den
letzten zwei drei Jahren mit guten
Menschen Strukturen um mich herum gebaut
die ist mir erlauben mich weiterhin
weiterzuentwickeln in meiner Arbeit
ehrgeizig zu bleiben inhaltliche
Freiheit zu haben aber mit nachhaltigen
Arbeitsprozessen für mich und meine
Familie und auch für Jens Solars und
ihre Familien und bevor es gleich noch
mal ein bisschen emotional wird vor noch
ganz kurz eine Sache die mich auch ein
bisschen tröstet Kanäle hören auf aber
neue entstehen circle of Life und zwar
Funk sucht gerade neue science Creator
für Youtube tiktok Twitch und so weiter
wenn ihr also aus der Wissenschaft kommt
wenn ihr idealerweise auch schon
Erfahrung vor der Kamera habt oder auf
der Bühne wenn ihr Lust habt jungen
Menschen Wissenschaft zu vermitteln also
die Zielgruppe von Funk ist 14 bis 29
Jahre dann meldet euch unter dieser
E-Mail-Adresse und zwar mit einem 60
sekündigen Video also kann natürlich
auch geschnitten sein aber 60 Sekunden
zu einem Science Thema eurer Wahl und
ein ganz frischen Kanal kann ich euch
jetzt schon empfehlen und zwar Sonne tot
und Sterne mit Sina hier haben wir uns
getroffen als sie damals den Piloten für
dieses Format gedreht hat sina ist
Physikerin und hat ein sehr
da können Humor weswegen ist bei
sondertod und Sterne nicht nur um
Astrophysik geht sondern auch um die
verschiedenen Wege wie genau dieser
Planet zerstört werden kann kompletter
Albtraum schaut vorbei und gebt Sina ein
bisschen science auf und Kekse mit helft
ihr mit diesem ganz neuen Kanal auf die
Beine kommen und sagte liebe Grüße von
mir ja und jetzt noch mal zu uns ich bin
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen emotional
aber vor allem auch dankbar und nicht
nur ich liebe Community ich bin ja als
letztes relationsmitglied zu meiner
gekommen und trotzdem habt ihr in dieser
relativ kurzen Zeit die ich dabei war
komplett mein Leben verändert nur zum
Guten und zwar mit jedem juhu jedem like
jedem Kommentar den hinterlassen habt
vielen Dank dafür ich bin euch sehr
dankbar für eure Treue und eure
Unterstützung dir den Kanal gezeigt hat
und vor allem wenn ich ehrlich bin den
ich euch vor allem dankbar für euer
Interesse an der Wissenschaft und zwar
egal wo sie hinführen mag solange wir
uns das beibehalten solange ihr euch das
beibehaltet kriegen wir das alles
zusammen in vielen Dank und wir sehen
uns mylab steht für mich dafür dass es
eben doch ein großes Publikum gibt für
wissenschaftliche Beiträge die die nicht
nur an Oberfläche bleiben bei vielen
wissenschaftlichen Themen muss man
einfach ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen
um überhaupt erst an den an den Stellen
anzukommen die interessant sind oder
oder die wichtig sind
ja und wenn man das macht und dann
vielleicht auch ein bisschen weiter
ausholt dafür dann dann schalten eben
nicht alle ab sondern
es gibt auch Leute die da bleiben und
sich einfach ein Thema machen
also auch von mir vielen Dank dass ihr
dabei wart dass ihr euch für unsere
Videos interessiert hat
und bleibt sicher hey Freunde der Sonne
das ist ein krass emotionaler Moment
heute
als ich 2016 die Idee zu diesem Format
hatte und bei mai angeklopft habe hatte
ich keine Ahnung auch was für eine
verrückte Reise wieder zusammen gehen
und heute will ich vor allem danke sagen
Danke an das beste Team der Welt mein
Jens Lars ich
habe euch lieb und ich will Danke sagen
an die beste Community der Welt denn
ohne euch wäre dieses Format ohne euch
wäre mein App niemals das geworden
was es ist was es war
danke für Alles danke auch an den SWR
vor allem an Melanie Chef michelbad
danke Funk für diese einfach super gute
Zeit auch danke dafür dass Sie immer
unseren Fokus auf Recherche verstanden
habt dass ich sogar Jens und Lars
Vollzeit einstellen konnte das ist nicht
selbstverständlich danke für die volle
Unterstützung bei allem und Freunde der
Sonne seid nicht traurig ich will
jedenfalls nicht traurig sein
zumindest nicht nur sondern vor allem
dankbar danke dass ihr dabei wart danke
dass ihr durch eure Aufmerksamkeit
diesen Kanal überhaupt ist eine
Bedeutung gegeben hat danke für eure
witzigen und intelligenten Kommentare
Nachrichten die uns wirklich täglich
motiviert haben weiter zu machen es war
eine geile Zeit Leute und ähm ihr werdet
mich ja Wiedersehen nach der Babypause
mit anderen Projekten aber mit genauso
viel Liebe und genauso viel
wissenschaftliche ich natürlich freuen
wenn ihr mich weiterhin supportet bei
Mike x und Terra x und bei all den
anderen Sachen die nach der Babypause
noch kommen und Großteil der Community
ist ja eh bei insta und Kurse kommt
rüber weiß noch nicht geschehen bis
dahin lass uns mit T anstoßen und Kekse
essen passt auf Euch auf es war mir ein
Fest
der Vorhang zu das Licht geht aus
es ist vorbei das war der letzte Applaus
ein Blick zurück dann wird es still
und niemandem ein
Wort etwas sagen will
denn das ist jetzt der Moment in dem
alles endet und neu beginnt wohin wollen
wir jetzt gehen
noch nie weiß so schön im Dunkeln zu
stehen noch nie weiß so schön gar nichts
zu sehen noch nie weiß so leicht die
Dinge zu verstehen ich freue mich schon
jetzt darauf
dich wiederzusehen
[Musik]